peter als du diese bilder am samstag
geschickt das haben wir gesprochen und
ich habe gesagt das waren wirklich für
mich die symbolbilder dieses tages die
die ganze verzweiflung und auch den mut
und kampfeswillen der ukraine zum
ausdruck bringen wo bist du jetzt
thomas wir sind wieder außerhalb von
schmolinski dieser stadt industriestadt
270.000 einwohner an einem checkpoint
hier wird jetzt der ring immer enger
gezogen das heißt die territorial kräfte
versuchen hier jetzt die stadt ein wenig
sicherer zu machen ab zu regeln man will
hier kontrollieren dass hier keine
sabotage einheiten reinkommen getarnt
als zivilisten um dann eventuell
kritische infrastruktur sabotieren zu
können mit sprengstoff oder mit mit mit
bomben im falle dass ihr dann
angegriffen wird und wir können mal
hierhin schauen wir haben jetzt hier auf
der seite jetzt die ersten
vorbereitungen sind panzer stellung
ausgegraben worden hier kommen wir gehen
mal bisschen näher heran wir sehen hier
sollen dann wenn es denn zu angriffen
kommt die einheiten sich verschanzen um
dann das können wir jetzt aus
sicherheitsgründen dich zeigen dass
vorliegende territorium bekämpfen zu
können mit panzerfäusten und mit
ähnlichen waffen um heranrückende
russische einheiten zu stoppen das ist
im moment die situation ich habe gerade
mit betroffenheit die dramatische
reportage haben wir verfolgt von paul
das sind 10 die sind natürlich noch
nicht hier angekommen aber das ist genau
das was die menschen hier befürchten
denn hier diese stadt befindet sich
genau auch in auf der schnittstelle
zwischen westen und osten zwischen polen
und tier das heißt hier geht die
versorgung durch hier werden waffen auch
rhein transportiert nach kiew bzw in die
umliegenden städte und hier werden auch
hilfsgüter transportieren also das ist
ein neuralgischer punkt 120 kilometer
östlich von uns in
manager ist der flughafen gestern
bombardiert worden genau das befürchtet
man hier auch das eben jetzt auch hier
die kritische infrastruktur angegriffen
wird wir haben mehrfach alarm gehabt in
dieser nacht ist wurde gestern von der
kommune gewarnt dass die stadt damit
rechnet dass bombenangriffe hier
stattfinden man soll sich vorbereiten
man soll sich anziehen das heißt man
soll sich nicht aussehen oder ins bett
geht sondern mit schuhen schlafen also
hier bereitet man sich jetzt die
nächsten tage geben ebenfalls auf
angriffe vor peter wie wir sehen bei dir
hat es geschneit die letzten tage war es
nicht so kalt man merkt auch richtig ja
die kälte in deinem atem beschreibt mal
was so etwas spielt das wetter und diese
eisige temperaturen für eine rolle
im prinzip leider keine gute militär
militärisch ausgedrückt also für die
menschen natürlich schrecklich wir haben
hinten hier die kampf stände das sieht
aus wie im ersten weltkrieg da sind
offen tonnen die schlafen dann nachts
drin wir haben nachts minus sieben grad
wir haben jetzt auch minus vier grad
aber wenn der boden gefroren ist
bedeutet das dass dort auch
transportmittel bewegt werden können das
ist im moment so ein bisschen das war im
moment so ein bisschen das problem der
vorrückenden russischen einheiten es war
warm die felder waren nass matschig da
konnten die konvois nicht drüber gehen
das heißt sie mussten alle auf straßen
nach vorne gehen und wenn man hier so
eine enge straße sieht und man überlegt
da sind irgendwie panzer und große
konvois und transportwagen da geht das
nur in eine richtung vor sind die felder
gefroren ist es knüppelhart wie jetzt
zum beispiel wenn wir mal ein bisschen
drüber schwenken wissen wir oder weiß
das militär sie können ausreichen das
heißt sie können ohne stecken zu bleiben
auf diesen festgefahren auf diesen fest
gefrorene boden nach vorne gehen wir
wissen jetzt nicht wie die temperaturen
in kiew sind hier ist es auf jeden fall
eise kalt alles ist gefroren dh man kann
auch auf feldern weiter nach vorne
marschieren man kann mit den kolonnen
weiter aus weiß man muss sich auf diesen
engen straße sein und diese temperatur
ist daneben auch ausschlaggebend bitte
herr mitten in der ukraine auf halben
weg ungefähr zwischen kiew und der
polnischen grenze vielen dank